ce serait tout à fait différent si
effectivement google nous était facturé
à hauteur de 500 dollars par an puisque
c'est la valeur des données qu'on lui
fournit l'entreprise qui utilisera 10%
de ces données fera le plus gros chiffre
d'affaires de tous les temps
il y à des entreprises inconnu qui
déclare avoir environ 1500 donné par
citoyen américain moyen dans un volume
pareil ça ne doit pas être facile de
trouver des détails particuliers sur
quelqu'un tu y fais super facile en fait
en quelques minutes vous savez pour qui
les gens ont voté à quelles sont leurs
problèmes psychologiques
à quelle soirée ils ont été quand on
accepte les conditions du contrat c'est
pour les considère comme valable et
c'est terrifiant
il est bien plus facile pour le
gouvernement d'obtenir des informations
par google ou facebook que d'aller les
chercher en vous mettant sur écoute on
est obligé de confier ses moyens à
quelqu'un comme récemment les réseaux
sociaux si vous faites quelque chose qui
ne doit pas se savoir mieux vaudrait
peut-être ne pas le faire du tout toutes
ces puissantes institutions
les gens semblent bien les accepter si
ce n'était pas le cas il serait à qui
s'adresser